[Music]
this
auction represents amazing treasures
from janet jackson's life and career
when i say life i mean her
childhood dolls you know furnishings
from her various homes
there's her what we call her closet
which will take a tour
and i'll show you like all her luggage
and her personal shoes and her personal
wardrobe
and then we have like the red carpet
area where we've all the amazing gowns
she wore to
so many different red carpet events of
course where i'm standing is
representing her stage performances her
music videos
and and so it's really a diverse auction
taking place over three days we've been
asking her for years if she would let go
some of her items because it's so
almost impossible to find anything in
the public domain from janet jackson's
life and career
and so in 2019 she agreed to do an
auction it was going to be 200 lots
may of 2020 and so we began the process
and then suddenly the pandemic hit
and that changed everything now it felt
right for her
she has her young son she's focusing on
and she wanted the fans an opportunity
to own some of these items and at the
same time
raise some money for her charity which
is compassion international
my mother's always said that i've always
been concerned with other people
before myself when you think of michael
jackson you know you think of him with
one glove janet was very famous for
wearing this earring with an actual key
and not just a key but a working key a
key that she used when she was feeding
the animals in indiana and here in
california that was her chore
and then she wore it as a teenager and
then she took it on tour for rhythm
nation and it's so iconic
so famous a huge interest in this i hope
you enjoy this as much as i do
are we ready i am
people are already going to
julianslife.com they can see all the
items
and they're actually placing bids
already and of course the auction takes
place
live here at julian's auctions in
beverly hills this friday saturday
and sunday and that was janet's wish
that her auction would take place over
her birthday weekend and of course
we're celebrating janet's birthday this
sunday the estimate on this because it's
so
iconic we estimated four to six thousand
i think that's very conservative i think
already online it surpassed that
i was talking with everybody about your
different looks the different looks you
always have
what's your favorite look 24 play would
be one if would be another
um what's it going to be that i did with
buster
yeah yeah yeah i love that scream is
another this is so amazing the course
screamed that very famous video
may 1995 26 years ago this month with
her brother michael jackson of course
the most expensive music video ever
created seven million dollar budget it's
in the guinness book of world records
has been the most expensive video
so iconic amazing performances of course
this coat
so recognizable with the lamb's wool
lining
and of course two more looks from screen
the black outfit
the white outfit and of course mike and
her brother wore a summer outfit in fact
we sold that a few years ago
this outfit was worn by janet jackson in
1995 to the mtv
video music awards she was there with
her brother michael jackson of course
and the nomination was for scream i
couldn't imagine any
cooler place to be than here tonight
janet wore this
outfit in a tribute to her brother
michael jackson at the video music
awards in new york city
in 2009
1990 and again this is so recognizable
the hat
this jacket and the gloves of course she
wore leather gloves as well
these are the satin gloves and again
this is all sold as one lot and we
estimate
four to six thousand
this was the rhythm nation album it was
a music video
love will never do and it was a
different side of janet jackson that we
had known because we think of
rhythm nation detour and she had all
those police and military style
black jackets and the hats and the
gloves et cetera and then we got
this which was a new revelation for a
different side of janet
and of course this music video was
directed by her breasts
i remember being in the dressing room
and her hair was piled up like this and
she had the makeup and all that and
she's going i don't know i don't know i
said let's just go and i just said
literally like pushed her out of the
out of the motorhome and said let's just
go grab her hand and put her right up on
the set
this is that wedding dress that janet
jackson wore to her secret wedding in
1991
nobody has ever seen any pictures of
this before but they are included in our
catalogue
[Music]
this outfit was worn by janet jackson in
the music video
if in 1993. if was one of janet's most
instantly recognizable music videos
this incredible outfit worn by janet
jackson the opening
scene in her world tour 93 to 95 and of
course
she wears this performing if
[Applause]
we also have outlets in the videos all
for you
and also the video when i think of you
[Music]
this is one of the many outfits we have
from the music video calling me that
janet performed with nelly
[Music]
and these two outfits are from the
feedback music video
this is the outfit that janet wore in
the rock with you tour in 2008 the
opening sequence she's saying pleasure
principles she also saying control
and what have you done for me lately
[Music]
and this exquisite gown it's atelier
versace
and of course it's from the rock with
you tour in 2008
just amazing and beautiful red shoes
also with this outfit we estimate this
four to six thousand again very
conservative but
again just so iconic and look around we
have her two
road cases as well her the chairs she
took on tour
you know this is incredible action
[Music]
we invite all the fans and people that
are curious about these items to come to
our exhibition
we're open to the public eleven to five
every day it's free
and come and take a trip down memory
lane we're here every day through sunday
janet is invited and we would certainly
love if she was here
and we wouldn't be surprised if she did
make an appearance and because it's her
birthday this weekend she may want to be
home with her mom for her birthday so
it's very possible we we have everything
ready for her
this lady is a very busy mom but she's
certainly no intention of retiring she's
all looking for the next pro project the
next
challenge and so i expect we're going to
see a lot
more of janet to come which we're very
thankful for but for now this gave her a
time to just reflect
it's cathartic for her liberating just
downsize
let go and then start again
you